el aborto Nunca ha dejado de ser eje
central de la escena política
estadounidense miles de manifestantes
protagonizaron la anual marcha por la
vida en las calles de Washington la
primera sin el aborto legal en Estados
Unidos tras la decisión de la corte de
derogar la decisión de 1973 en dos días
se habrían cumplido 50 años del
histórico fallo de raw versus White con
el que la Corte Suprema protegió
federalmente el derecho de una mujer a
interrumpir su embarazo
nos está mostrando y dando Esperanza que
los jóvenes de Estados Unidos apoyan la
vida defienden la vida están aquí para
marchar por la vida porque cuando estás
en una batalla es importante mantener el
enfoque de Cuál es la misión pero en
cada paso del camino también es
fundamental que celebremos las victorias
y obtuvimos una gran Victoria hace solo
unos meses cuando Row fue anulado
los manifestantes buscan ahora
restricciones al aborto a nivel Federal
en contrapartida el presidente Joe biden
afirmó que continuará sus esfuerzos por
restaurar el derecho al aborto en todo
el país
Mi administración se mantiene firme en
su compromiso para defender los derechos
reproductivos y continuar el progreso de
nuestra nación hacia la igualdad para
todos este caso reafirmó principios
básicos de igualdad refuerzo el derecho
fundamental a la privacidad y sostuvo
que las mujeres de este país podían
controlar su propio destino tomando
decisiones profundamente personales
libres de injerencia política
sin las protecciones que otorgaba Rover
versus Wayne el aborto se convirtió en
territorio de disputas judicial en todos
los estados desde junio una docena de
ellos han implementado prohibiciones
casi totales mientras que tribunales
estatales bloquearon esfuerzos similares
en otros tres estados unidos oscila
entre las perturbaciones generadas a los
derechos reproductivos y el deseo de
mayores prohibiciones reflejo de una
sociedad altamente polarizada